6 24 it's a monday morning well the
price is right is back this week
unfortunately though alex no audience
yeah filming stopped back in march
because of the pandemic like most other
things
but it's now taping again after months
and months of planning so the set was
reconfigured actually to add some social
distance
safety protocols include cleaning and
testing and the price is right executive
producer
says one thing was not negotiable
come on down you don't hear george
say come on down at the top of the show
it's not the price is right
so i think for us the biggest challenge
was how are we going to do
a come on down without an audience
and we struggled with that yeah you got
to have that contestants do wait
backstage with a mask on still a
surprise if their name is called
and they get to run out on stage but
they are not allowed to give host drew
carey
any bear hugs anymore or knock him over
which he says he doesn't mind
as for carrie he debuted a new look to
be honest a lot of this stuff about
kovid
if you haven't been sick it's kind of
been a little bit of a blessing disguise
to be shut down so much because i had a
lot of time for
introspection a lot of spiritual growth
this
uh this summer part of me wanted to
reflect it with
a different look so let me throw a beard
and see what it looks like and then i
liked it when it came out and i kept it
the price is right first aired on cbs
back in 1972.
bob barker hosted that show for 35 years
before passing the mic
to drew carey it is tv's longest running
game show and you can watch the audience
free
prime time special it's airing on
channel 8 it airs tomorrow night
at eight o'clock hard to imagine bob
barker rocking the same beard that drew
carey has right now it's like ready
to have the same look no it's not the
same effect